[موسيقى] لا
تزال قبور المقاتلين الأكراد في كوباني ما زالت
حية محمود رسول ، البالغ من العمر 27 عامًا ،
قُتل قبل أقل من أسبوعين
في كمين لداعش بالقرب من بلدة دير
الزور ،
استيقظ ابني ، أتوسل إليك
والدته نزمة تبكي
هذه  الأشخاص الذين تركوا وراءهم
حدادًا
الآن هم يستعدون للحظة التي
سيتركونهم خلفهم مرة أخرى
حيث بدأت الولايات المتحدة في سحب قواتها
من سوريا ،
لقد حصلوا على ما أرادوا ، استخدموا
الأكراد للتخلص من داعش والآن يتركوننا.
يقول نزما إن أمريكا كان من المفترض أن تساند ظهرنا ،
فقد فقدت كل أسرة في هذه المدينة
شخصًا ما
في هذه الحرب ، والخوف الحقيقي هنا
الآن
هو أنه عندما يغادر الأمريكيون
ستكون هناك حرب
هنا مرة أخرى فقط عبر الحدود
هي
تركيا التي ترى  الأكراد السوريين كإرهابيين
إلى الغرب هو النظام الوحشي
لبشار الأسد وداعميه الروس والإيرانيين القائد العسكري الكردي شرفان
درويش يخبرنا أن الأمريكيين
قدموا للأكراد حاجزًا
في المقابل  أخذ الأكراد القتال إلى
داعش بادكولا
حيث
يمكن رؤية الخليط المعقد للقوى المختلفة عن قرب ،
لذا فإن النظام والروس
موجودون هناك ،
نقترب من قاعدة النظام الروسي المشتركة
، من الخطر جدًا أن نتوقف على بعد أقل من
خمس دقائق من الأمريكيين  لا
يزالون يرفعون علمهم ،
لكن لن يكون هناك لفترة طويلة ،
لقد بدأت العتاد العسكري الأمريكي بالفعل
في الخروج ،
ولا أحد يعرف ما الذي سيأتي بعد ذلك
للأكراد
على طريق العودة إلى كوباني ، لقد حدثنا
في جنازة
ضابطي أمن كرديين قتلوا على
يد  قنبلة مزروعة على الطريق
تذكير بالمخاطر اليومية التي نواجهها
هنا
بعد معركة مرهقة ضد
داعش ، قد يضطر الأكراد الآن للدفاع عن
أنفسهم ضد أعداء أقوى
لوحدهم كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن
شمال سوريا